okay so mint Press news.com is where you
can get these articles you've done a
four-part series on Jeffrey Epstein and
the fourth part is coming out soon there
are no breaks this week Whitney
[Music]
let me ask you a question because we're
gonna get into some of the background
that made you know a guy like Jeffrey
Epstein powerful and so dangerous
especially his testimony but just look
at the actual story of the suicide I
know that I you know you've been on
Twitter you're reading a lot of the same
new sources that I am as a journalist as
somebody who's inherently skeptical of
the mainstream narrative you know this
guy was supposedly on suicide watch he
supposedly had tried to commit suicide I
think it was last week or two weeks ago
he's in one of the most tightly guarded
closely guarded facilities in America
the Metropolitan Detention Center in
downtown Manhattan which I which is
where the held El Chapo is there
anything we are just about the forget it
Jeffrey Epstein and forget everything
that we know is there anything weird
about the consistency of the story as it
stands right now
this morning you know today right so
every source reports you know mainstream
media so for example there were reports
I believe from CNN that said that
Epstein was originally taken to a
hospital at 3:30 in the morning or
between 3:00 and 4:00 in the morning
allegedly for a cardiac arrest and the
New York Times says that he hung himself
even though he was supposed to be on
suicide watch and took himself and then
he was taken to the hospital around like
7:30 or something like that and he was
already unresponsive and then always had
a story where they said that Epstein had
he was worried about being murdered and
his his alleged previous suicide attempt
that happened a few weeks ago that he
said that someone had tried to kill him
and this was just for mainstream right
so no one no one's gonna be throwing the
conspiracy theorist label on them right
so there it's really hard to know
exactly what's going on and until that
is sorted it's gonna be difficult but
the problem is now is that the FBI is
going to be investigating and the person
ultimately with responsibility or you
know Epstein's death it was my
understanding this was you know sort of
a facility run more or less you know the
you know he was killed by the Department
of Justice and Bill bar you know is the
Kearney general he's gonna be you know
influential in the outcome of this
investigation and let's remember that
bill bars the guy got his start at the
CIA's office like like legal counsel I
forget the exact name sorry I'm blanking
on it but he helped Stonewall the church
committee in the night late 1970s when
they were investigating the CIA's covert
and of course when he was Attorney
General under George Bush Senior in the
early 90s he helped us apply the pardons
of all the iran-contra criminals so this
is a lot of people
that we're connected to Iran cultures
like pointed out on my series we're also
connected to some of these sexual
blackmail operations that exploited
children like Jeffrey Epstein so the
fact that the bar is going to be
influential massive in this
investigation isn't recusing himself is
problematic I would say yeah we we've
done a lot of work on this show with
people like I don't know if you're
familiar with a guy named Nick Bryant
and wrote a book called the Franklin
scandal that's exactly right
Nick's done a lot of work in the in the
area of sexual blackmail to somebody who
doesn't know what we're talking about or
is confused and doesn't really know why
these operations are so incredibly
secret and why takes so long to get any
information on them if you ever do what
would you tell somebody who's just
completely unaware of of what sexual
blackmail is and how its practiced by
intelligence agencies and powerful
people around the world and you know the
sexual blackmail operations it's really
hard to justify the use of you know
underage you know children in these
operations and claim that's in the
interest of national security that's
where this becomes a problem and that's
a large reason I
say that a lot of this was stonewalled
and one example that was stonewalled by
the CIA when the church committee was
going on were these sexual blackmail
operations that leaked out to the press
during that time and they were called
you know the CIA's love traps and they
would have these apartments and they
would hire prostitutes or other people
to learn foreign diplomats specifically
into these bugged apartments CIA would
be in the neighboring apartment there'd
be like two-way mirrors on the wall and
there'd be all this recording
intelligence agencies all over the world
use it everywhere from South Korea's
Intelligence Agency to Israel's Messiah
it's really expensive because it's it's
a very it's a very widely used way to
get leverage over certain political
players by luring them into this and
then having you know stuff over their
heads that you can use to get them to do
certain things they normally wanted
agree to yeah the intelligence agencies
necessarily yes and you did the other
thing I like about your piece is that
you you look at this very powerful group
of billionaires who's bankrolling a lot
of not only charitable organizations but
political candidates and you know they
have a lot of connections all over the
world and you call them the mega group
can you talk a little bit about them
because they made their fortune you know
that the Seagrams company and all of
that really rose to prominence because
of their ties of the mob and they were
supplying Canadian liquor to the west so
the group sort of didn't really I didn't
really get much media attention so there
Wall Street Journal report on it and may
of nineteen and there it talked about
all these individuals coming together
before I'm sort of informal group and
they would have meetings you know a few
times a year they would pay they have
dues of like thirty thousand dollars at
least I'm the wall street I'll report it
on it so this isn't some sort of like me
made up this is the name The Wall Street
Journal gave to them so a lot of people
here are big political players as well
one of the earliest members of the group
is a guy named Max Fisher he created the
Jewish coalition which later became the
Republican Jewish coalition and today
that is one of the most powerful lobby
groups political groups in the
Republican Party trumps president
Trump's two largest donors a Sheldon
Adelson and Bernard Marcus or super
involved in that group and they're on
its board primaries in the last
Republican primaries for example we saw
Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz and Trump all
vying for that endorsement from that
group to Jeffery millions of dollars
millions more refurnishing it including
with a bathroom for no money right some
other people that are connected to
Epstein directly would be Ronald Lauder
who I piece there's a really strong case
for him being supplied I've seen with
his
passport which is one of the things
seized on the raid on his Manhattan
townhouse show in the mega group in my
piece is they have a lot of times most
of its prominence members have direct
ties to organized crime so it's sort of
like they use philanthropy is the cover
for the fact that they're sort of part
of this intergenerational mob so for
example Michael Steinhardt another
person who's a big name in the mega
group his dad was mayor Lansky's Joel
fence and was a member of the mob and so
what I'm trying to show my earlier
pieces to because the mega group where I
talk about that that's really laying out
for decades the mega group and showing
that's direct ties great right and it's
it's fascinating out what you did you
know distinguish in your piece is that
it you know when you have an operation
like this that's you know it has a lot
of these figures that are connected to
the Mossad or connected in some way to
Israel there's a tendency to say well
this is all a Mossad operation or it's
all predominantly you know Jewish
businessmen but what you say is there's
there's a lot more going on and the idea
that the Mossad would be running an
operation with an American citizen and
the CIA not know about it is kind of
ridiculous like this would have to be an
operation that had the CIA's blessing if
the CIA was not directly involved in I
mean isn't it it's bigger than any one
Intelligence Agency it's like this dark
nexus between the private sector and
incredibly powerful people there and the
government it doesn't seem to be anyone
government and it doesn't seem to be
like anyone Intelligence Agency
Intelligence Agency I mean they're there
you have to
nor some of the ties that come up when
you're investigating this case stuff
they claim that it's just one group
right um so what I try and show here is
that you know if you step back and you
look about how the really world works so
several foreign governments you know are
basically you know there are nominally
democracies but they're often look
called they're often called you know
oligarchies really and the u.s. is often
you know wealthy political donors have
more influence than the regular voting
public for example countries and so when
people are talking about the CIA and the
Mossad
you know the Mossad answers directly to
the Prime Minister of Israel and in
several Israeli elections there have
been complaints actually from people
insight is really about the large number
of foreign donors who end up being king
makers and Israeli politics so for
example I think it was 2009 and Yahoo's
run in 2009 it might have been 2010 I
forget my Minister an Israeli media
reported that more than 90% of his
donation from foreign donors right so
you know we're talking about the Mossad
too sometimes you know the interest of
Israeli politicians you know can be
influenced by foreign oligarchs that's
also true in the US and it's also worth
pointing out that intelligence agencies
in the past including the United States
sometimes carry out covert actions sodor
certain certain things to paper
oligarchs so an example in the CIA's
case would be when the CIA first began
overthrowing government's in the in the
early fifties for example droite Amala
or iran they were doing that to benefit
large corporations the people would own
those corporations so in Guatemala it
was that a Fruit Company in Iran Anglo
American oil a small moneyed class and
what I'm saying here is that we for
example there's a lot of overlap between
oligarchies in the u.s. countries
including Israel's that's why some
people have looked at this and said it's
point CIA Mossad it's worth pointing out
too that the CIA from it's early days
has had a lot of collaboration with the
Mossad this was because the first CIA
intelligence sheep you can go and look
this up his name is James she's
10 he was the guy that ran was the
liaison between the CIA and the Mossad
and he was very pro-israel and worked to
really forge close ties between the two
intelligence agencies I mean this is a
matter of public and he was also
angleton was also the guy that was the
CIA leaves and organized crime to the
mob specifically mayor lamb you know
three-way relationship for a long time
and in these days when Angleton was
doing this was when this nexus as I show
my reports was really first starting to
develop and so that's how you know
Jeffrey Epstein really came to be who he
was because there's this network had
grown and proliferated for long before
him right so actually was not just a
fluke as some you know more mainstream
outlets have tried to say like oh he's
just this one random billionaire doing
this horrible thing you know these sort
of horrible things have been going on
for decades and they haven't really
gotten who do you think had the most to
lose if Epstein went into that courtroom
who do you think from your research was
you know having sleepless nights the
last couple of weeks exactly which ones
to lose in my opinion Leslie Wexner is a
big one because he I guess you can say
flack because it came Epstein's wealth
it was also known that Leslie Wexner in
1996 Epstein at his place commissioned
an artist to be work at Wagner's mansion
I've seen sexually assaulted a woman she
called the police and a Webster's
personal security let her leave for 12
hours and as I mentioned earlier how he
gave that townhouse with Epstein for
like a dollar so he definitely maybe he
wouldn't have wanted that scrutiny
another person also a hoot Barak has
been getting savaged in Israel and
Israel's been elections because I
suppose ties to Epstein
currently running against Yahoo for the
position of Prime Minister and Israel's
elections that are coming up soon and so
Netanyahu himself right is under all
these corruption investigations and he
was worried about that weakening his you
know chances and that upcoming campaign
but with Epstein's arrest and all these
ties to Epstein coming out if more come
out of his clothes size what they could
Barak which are pretty much documented
and you know that was you know a lot of
political fodder for Netanyahu to use
again say what do you think about our
local darlings Bill and Hillary Clinton
and from from Arkansas you know both of
them had ties to the same group and they
were also know with Epstein you know you
know their exact ties go I'm gonna be
talking about the Clintons him and
Epstein a little bit about think you
know in both cases you know they were
definitely you know in both those cases
many victims accused you know Bill Bill
Clinton or Donald Trump directly as you
know in game you could say you're
getting massages Odom quote massages you
know from these girls so I think it may
have been more people like you know Alan
Dershowitz for example he's been feeling
the heat recently that would be more
concerned than say someone like Bill
Clinton or someone like Donald Trump I
think that have come out recently that
would be more correct and I'd seem to
sort of clear for some at least you know
it was coming out on right-wing media
you know they sort of cleared the air
for people like Trump in Gershowitz say
they gave them like you know some more
they helped strengthen their claims that
they weren't involved or something like
that so I mean who really it's hard to
know exactly you know who stood to
benefit the most from have students
death so I think that may become more
clear with time but I definitely think
there were so many people wrapped up in
this and it was so big and there's
so much reporting that has kept
attention the public's attention you
know focused on this case I think there
were a lot of people that do not like
that specifically and also didn't want
more documents coming out let's remember
to ghilane Maxwell is very
well-connected herself she's very
connected Clinton's as well was that
Chelsea clip was budding right and she
hasn't been charged with a crime and now
that Epstein is dead you know there are
people asking where is she why hasn't
she been charged it's been accusations
against her by many of Epstein's victims
if she was his alleged you know procurer
of girls is madam or whatever you want
to call it so I mean she would also have
an interest in him not being around I
think as well much to do that her father
was a was known to be an agent of the
Mossad Robert Maxwell who was also known
for his small media empire do you think
there's any chance that his slain
Maxwell gets indicted now because I
honestly was intelligence working with
intelligence by all indications that
would make d'Alene his handler right and
so usually it's doesn't get charged
right so now when you look at Epstein
suicide and I know you're a reporter and
you might you know not love to speculate
but I know you do all of your pieces are
very well sourced very well researched
but let's say you had to speculate you
know what would you say happened here do
you think it's plausible that you know
cuz even if he was allowed to kill
himself that still suggests a conspiracy
because you should have been monitored
you know or do you think it's possible
that he was actually murdered like I
said earlier it's really I mean there's
so much information that comes up I was
like break it's hard to know what's
going on that being said there were a
lot of people that wanted this guy dead
he had according to the Washington Post
so that he had you know that previous
suicide
was a suicide attempt that people tried
to kill him so I think there's a lot of
different this is prerecorded right can
you ask the question again sorry yeah no
that's okay yeah I was just I'm just
basically like if you gotta go out on a
limb you got a you know guess you know
is is this a situation where yeah are
they leaving a cell door open you like
how does this happen
type of thing there's Hillary Clinton go
in there and string him up herself this
does she dress like a prison guard
suicide right and there's been people
investigative journalist for the BBC
Gordon Thomas I become because he became
a liability even though he had and what
they were doing and what they were
trying to do with him and whatnot but
eventually he became a liability on
because of his his problems his money
problems and whatever and so they offed
him and a lot of people even mainstream
press have pointed out that Maxwell's
death on his suicide was very suspicious
he supposedly just like walked off the
boat and took off all his clothes before
doing so and then showed up naked like
really far away before the boat had been
and there's a lot of weird things going
on there and I sort of talked about in
part 3 how a lot of this group I'm
talking you know this network I mapped
out was connected to the promise
software in the in slaw scandal and all
of that in the 80s and the same year
Maxwell that 1991 of course Maxwell was
involved in that software so were other
people that were either investigating
that software involved in the scandal
end up dying that includes Senator John
towers who helped sell that bug software
to Los Alamos laboratory he died in a
sketchy plane crash a few months before
Maxwell and then there was the
journalist Danny casolaro who was
investing
the promise software and all of that and
he was found a bit of a very suspicious
suicide in the hotel room I believe that
same year - Craig Spence was running a
the White House fall house ring or
cowboy ring and all of that that was
connected to people in the Reagan
administration and was exploiting
underage children for sexual blackmail
purposes he was also found dead that
year agencies when people that are their
assets or their agents turn out to be a
liability or you know crime and
connections to both I think make us you
know be very skeptical about this being
a suicide in addition to the fact that
there are all these conflicting stories
coming from all these different sources
and that bill Barr do a lot of these
people they write about that's
ultimately gonna say you know who did it
and whether or not it was actually a
suicide okay no that was that was great
listen only a few more questions you're
really amazing and I want people to read
your stuff what tell us about this
promise software this is one of the most
interesting things about your work that
I think people should be more familiar
with from what I understand it's a type
of software where they were supposed to
be like a quote unquote backdoor that
allowed Israel to spy let us know what
that is software that was really
revolutionary it was supposed to be used
for a specific reasons for handling
legal cases originally but it also
served to intelligence it's really a
personal tracking software because back
then remember computers were really
different the way networks worked was
really different so you know in order to
get as much information as possible on a
person in those days you would have to
go and search the person's name
and various databases and it was much
slower with this software let you do was
just search the name and one thing and
you could look up all the databases at
once and it allows you to the amass this
Pro you know all this information on a
person like almost immediately and so
that was really important it was first
used by the DOJ right and it was being
used by the DOJ it was leased to them by
Hamilton's company in slaw and it was
being used by the DOJ to successfully
increase the rate their conviction and
prosecution rate of money laundering and
organized crime and for anyone that's
familiar with vacant area or iran-contra
remember that money laundering was very
important to the CIA during those days
so in a close aide of Ronald Reagan he
was also I believe an envoy to Iran for
Reagan during this time he had developed
a friendship with the head of an Israeli
intelligence agency his name is rappy
Aten Rafi Eitan is probably best known
in the u.s. for being the handler of
convicted of Israeli or Mossad spy
Jonathan Pollard and so basically Brian
was complaining that this was being used
to go money laundering a to install an
opportunity for kids Intelligence Agency
and that they both could make a huge
profit and so they basically colluded to
put a backdoor into the software and
then so governments all over the world I
think ultimately and it ended up being
develop or sorry being installed the
bugged version by as many as 80
intelligence agencies around the world
what did that have to do at 9/11 it have
something to do with 9/11 or am I
completely off-base you know I'm not
gonna get into 9/11 in this case but
there are some overlapping figures like
but I didn't talk about that here I'm
just talking about what went on the 80s
and the early 90s with that and I'm
gonna be talking more about that in part
four
but I'm not gonna be going in tonight
people on my Twitter mentions say that
but I haven't looked into that are you
so now do you think and this is gonna be
my final question because everybody
should go to mint press news.com
because yeah because you are really one
of the best out there keep doing what
you're doing I really appreciate you
taking the time to talk with us the
articles are very meaty I read them and
reread them they're so good everybody
should read what you write going forward
what happens is this out of the news
cycle in a few days I mean I know that
you're cynical you have every right to
be cynical I did that by the way that
photo didn't even really look like
Jeffrey Epstein is there a is there any
chance that Jeffrey Epstein is back on
his island right now with Bill and
Hillary having mimosas right well listen
by the way the FBI right now the FBI
right now is handing out ar-15s to nerdy
white kids just so we can all change the
subject well if it depends on the public
we are fought mainstream outlets try and
control the narrative and if they try to
keep this you know they try and kill the
story you know they may succeed without
pushback from the public so anyone
listening that doesn't want the story to
go away it's important keep this you
know going on social media and bugging
journalists
they're not things like that absolutely
and tell everybody where they can find
you on social media and where they can
read these articles mint press news.com
on twitter @ underscore whitney web
she's got part for coming out in a
four-part series about Jeffrey Epstein
his operation and now I'm sure you'll be
looking more closely at a suicide murder
unfortunate accident whatever you want
to call it I appreciate you taking the
time to talk with us Whitney you're a
killer keep doing what you're doing
all right thanks babe
all right folks so we're still we're
still recording I'm gonna text Mullen
and see if I can grab him for 15 minutes
but mint press news.com she's got a
four-part series on Epstein it's a crazy
in-depth look at not only Epstein but a
lot of his business associates his
friends the circles he traveled in who
these people are what state-run
intelligence agencies they're connected
to what private corporations they're
connected to and how they really move
between one and the other seamlessly how
they leverage sexual blackmail how
they've done that really since World War
two as a way to compromise people to get
in from
from them this is just another in a long
line of operations that have been
carried out really for the most part
with impunity there's a lot of writing
about the things that have gone on but
none of its in the mainstream none of it
is resulted in any convictions certainly
of any of the people that were
responsible for this but it all goes
back to Alexander Acosta who was
Secretary of Labor that just stepped
down under President Trump who caught
Epstein the sweetheart deal he goes he
belonged to intelligence okay when the I
believe was a Tallahassee Police
Department found a bunch of disheveled
kids in a park and they connected them
to and they arrested members of the
finders cult and the case was dismissed
at the back of the police report it said
it became a CIA internal matter this is
this is not a new phenomenon of people
passing the buck and saying the CIA is
handling this CIA by the way not
supposed to be operating domestically at
all you know and this is you know to say
they're operating domestically as the
biggest euphemism ever for what they're
doing but so this is a very common a
relatively common refrain from people in
power this person belongs to
intelligence it became a CIA internal
matter so there you have it folks
Jeffrey Epstein who is about to be about
to go into open court and potentially
flip turn state's evidence name
co-conspirators inform on people that
help facilitate this operation on his
private island and I believe the French
Virgin Islands may be the British Virgin
Islands um found dead in his prison cell
after essentially I mean trying to kill
himself once reportedly
being placed on suicide watch in the
Metropolitan Detention Center one of the
most tightly guarded prisons in the
entire world certainly in in this
country found dead nothing to see there
you go we're gonna be back you know to
The Bachelor very soon we're gonna be
back to the Bachelor football The
Bachelor but was great about things like
this is that where your tinfoil hat
proudly today okay Sam Tripoli is out
there feeling very proud right now this
is a national holiday
so wear that tinfoil hat proudly your
family members these basic [ __ ] called
brew drinking liberals that wanna just
you know you're a conspiracy theorist
you know they've been [ __ ] talking
about Trump in Russia for 24 months and
now you're the conspiracy theorists yeah
conspiracies fast just know that today
today is your holiday today you are
right and they're wrong and the mental
gymnastics you have to do to not believe
that there is something very wrong with
this situation are truly amazing so
that's Whitney Webb man she's done a lot
of great work and it's very it's very
cool to to read some of the stuff that
she's done uh Tim Dilla comedy calm if
you want to come see live shows Tim Jay
Dylan di llo went on Twitter and
Instagram same handle TI m JD I ll oh
and this was your emergency podcast were
probably gonna get Mullin on in the next
couple of days but I wanted to talk to
Whitney she has a lot of great
information look at all that do a deep
dive get lost in that promise software
mega group
take some time it's Saturday it's your
weekend don't let anybody tell you how
you have to spend it
don't go pick up your kid cancel you
cancel them that that that lunch date
you have with your son or daughter
they'll understand you're busy okay
shits going on um the Tim Dylan show
this is just a little fun emergency
podcast for everybody
audio quality was you know she's skyping
in from another country you know they're
not letting us do this on the set of
Good Morning America so sorry for any
audio problems but don't [ __ ] at me
don't complain you know you you you got
a little perspective here read these
articles these are [ __ ] great
articles and you know Bill and Hill are
sitting in Chappaqua New York right now
Hillary's pouring hot sauce on an
aborted fetus and Bill's drinking a
blood smoothie and they're reading the
New York Times you know and they didn't
string them up they might not have
ordered the hit but I'll tell you right
now they're not upset there are no tears
being shed for Jeffrey up in Chappaqua
New York Bill and Hillary and the people
that are out there like defending Bill
and Hillary what are you doing what is
what are you doing I mean okay they
didn't they didn't do it themselves and
they probably didn't even order it but
they're part of the [ __ ] problem you
know they're part of the group of people
that are going if you're under you're
defending these two when will it end
well I mean they are not they are they
are the bushes and the Clintons they are
100 percent
they're not the bosses they're servants
there order takers for these big
billionaires and that is the class of
people they are but it doesn't mean they
are it does not mean that they're not
part of the very nasty and violent power
faction of people and they're certainly
they're certainly crime families and
they're certainly people that have
benefited from this guy not [ __ ]
opening his mouth Donald Trump maybe too
so let's get real so stop going on
Twitter and defending Hillary Clinton
because she went on Ellen enough grow up
all right thank you for listening folks
goodbye goodbye Jeffrey